[Music]  i'm a normal kid  dad i don't want to do this you got this  i'm a regular kid i'm normal  look i know you had a rough day  but i really want to show you something  to paul  [Music]  from mom  [Music]  there's some things that i've always  wanted to ask you paul  opened up about who i was  what's her name aristiana  that's a stupid name just because you  look like that  doesn't give you permission to be a dick  there's nothing to be ashamed of  we give the people what they want come  see  the dangerous dog boy go get a drink i'm  not old enough please you're never not  old enough for anything  this is a thicker oh my god give me the  money  paul this is a sticker  no more fairy tales  no more make-believe  this is pretty much all my fault  so what do we do now  [Music]  the world's gonna be mean to us no  matter what we do  so we can't afford to be mean to  ourselves  [Music]  i'm a normal kid and  i'll be strong  you